Cara I don't know if this has gotten out  much I don't know if I've ever said it I  I might be breaking the law now  but I'll say it the character I played  is is a guy he's like he's been around  he's done a lot of stuff and he also uh  chips cocaine oh my God  and I I always thought that that was a a  choice we made but yet not not showing  it she got off  great ass and you got your head all the  way up it but there is a seed in it  where it goes by really quick but which  we never get never got into the film  and I've always wanted to say sometimes  just so you know as some of the  behaviors coming from  okay  when I think of acids woman's ass  something comes out of me